Christianity has traditionally spoken a
lot about sinners in the fourth century
the church identified seven deadly sins
failings of character that were to be
particularly condemned and avoided by
all righteous people they were pride
being snobbish and boastful Envy ruff
getting very angry Galata knee eating
too much lust wanting to sleep around
sloth being lazy and finally greed
Christianity took these to be severe
faults of the soul that marked out a
person as a fitting target for scolding
and punishment God Himself would on the
day of judgment be remorseless with
sinners and send them to spend millennia
in the darker more tortured bits of
purgatory we may not use precisely such
traditional theological words today and
we may not imagine the creator of the
universe as someone who organizes
chastisement for people beyond the grave
but in the spirit in which we interpret
failings of character and responds to
people's less fortunate sides in the
online and real worlds we tend to retain
a similarly damning and ungenerous set
of attitudes we may feel that through
our harshness
we're helping humanity to improve but if
this is really our goal then it pays to
move beyond mere condemnation in an
attempt to understand what truly drives
people in their more regrettable moments
we stand to stumble on a surprising
truth behavior we call sinful is never
simply that it represents an unfortunate
first response to difficulty in distress
but could if it were properly understood
guided and forgiving be redirected
towards nobler ends we aren't evil so
much as in a lot of pain in a series of
areas let's consider each of the seven
sins in turn pride a can appear is if we
end up boasting and grandstanding
because we're so pleased with ourselves
far from it boasting is only never a
response to a feeling of in
ability we badly need to thrust forward
our own importance because behind the
scenes are very right to exist seems so
much in question we see it as almost
inevitable that others will think ill of
us unless we urgently and dramatically
assert our greatness that's why of all
people the proud don't need to be told
that terrible this is precisely what
they secretly think they are already
they need encouragement to feel a more
genuine pride in their own merits and
then to be spared the manic impulse
constantly to call them to the attention
of others Envy Envy is a graceless way
of confronting an idea that is in other
context and fundamental to decent
ambition as well as modesty of character
the notion that we are incomplete
imperfect and in need of improvement
envy grows from the legitimate insight
that others have something to teach us
mix together with a degree of inaccuracy
and panic about what this might actually
be Envy should in a perfect world be our
teacher
we should note when it strikes us sift
through its confused signals and use
them to work out our direction and
purpose the solution isn't to be made to
feel guilty for our envious attacks it's
to be helped to understand what's truly
missing from our lives Roth the mean
angry things we say when we're upset are
almost never truly meant they are the
result of panic and anxiety we call
someone a stupid fool because we are at
that moment terrified we shout because
we feel with waiting for our lives
therefore instead of being repeatedly
told how appalling it is to be angry we
of course know this quite well already
what we need is someone to demonstrate a
proper understanding of our underlying
fears you must be scared is the kindest
but also the most effective response to
any angry outburst it put its finger on
what's really going on we need others to
appreciate our fragility not berate us
for our wars gluttony we eat too many
chicken wings and toasted sandwiches
not because we're greedy but because
we're emotionally starving we want love
far more than we want calories we're
just at a loss as to how to find them so
the solution isn't to be told to eat
less as diet gurus and Christian
theologians suggest it's to be helped to
discover new sources of kindness
security and emotional connection our
appetite isn't essentially bad it simply
hasn't found its ideal target our excess
weight is a symbol of our background
emotional undernourishment lust we want
to keep jumping into bed with people not
out of degeneracy but because we are
lonely sex is the epitome of connection
and acceptance the so-called bad erotic
things we crave feel so exciting because
we read them as proofs of someone else's
open-ended affection which is in such
short supply in ordinary life ideally
we'd not be less lustful we'd be clearer
about what we genuinely need from sex
which is acceptance of our messy complex
and all-too-human selves sloth laziness
is really fear we can't bear to get down
to our work because if we were to apply
ourselves we risk a terrifying
humiliation we might not succeed as well
as we'd like we might find a task too
hard we may realize we're not yet
equipped to undertake it or be mocked by
the world
these aren't failings so much as hugely
understandable worries behind our
inaction is anticipated disaster a
catastrophe zhing mind
we will begin at last when the fear of
doing nothing at all Trump's the
crippling fear of doing something badly
greed
the powerful urge to take more than our
fair share is really a reaction to a
feeling of deprivation we felt so
neglected and vulnerable we require
never more our fear is so entrenched
we're trying to keep it at bay by
grabbing as much as we can as quickly as
possible to others we may look already
advantaged and privileged but inside we
just feel desperate
in short our so-called sins are not
signs of being bad people they are the
shape our unmet needs take when we
haven't found any better way of
addressing them we don't have to be
berated or threatened with hell we need
an open affection that welcomes us as we
are a forgiveness that doesn't involve
criticism and a tenderness that
delicately without humiliation locates
our true vulnerabilities and encourages
our own native appetite for reform we
love bringing you these films if you
want to help us to keep bringing you
thoughtful content please consider
supporting us by visiting our shop at
the link on your screen now
you